- It is obviously a thrill
and a real honor to be here
with all of you, with you Jack,
and recognizing not only
your accomplishments
but obviously all your family
has done for the country,
and with Mayor Brown.
There is no time, that
at least I can remember,
in American life, when the sacrifices
of what public servants do
every day has been more obvious
than in the last month or so,
so thank you and obviously, to you Jack,
for all the contributions of
your family to American life.
For me being here today,
I think symbolizes
not so much my own or BPI's own
accomplishments or achievements,
but finally after many
years, after a generation,
the central civil rights issue of our time
in the United States
finally coming to the fore
in the public imagination.
And I can't imagine a better
place for that to happen
than the John F. Kennedy Library,
who obviously above all else,
John Kennedy in the last
100 years of American life,
symbolized to Americans an idea
of optimism for the future,
and a sense that we had the capacity
to achieve things together.
And yet, over the last 30 or 40 years,
our biggest investment
domestically in American life
has not been in the things which someone
like President Kennedy prioritized.
In education, in healthcare,
in housing, or civil rights.
Our largest investment
has been in punishment,
particularly in prisons.
And over the course of
someone my age's lifetime,
or Mayor Brown's lifetime,
we have at the municipal
level, the state level,
and the national level,
incarcerated more and more people
for longer and longer periods of time,
often at younger and younger ages,
and for smaller and smaller
infractions of the law.
And we've done that and made prisons
the central public
institution in our lives,
in our civic lives, and we've
done that and simultaneously
gone out of our way to
make those prisons worse.
Make them less hopeful,
make them places where
less can be achieved for people
in prison and their families
and their communities during
incarceration and post release.
So, what we've done at Bard,
as you've seen in this video,
is create an institution
which was not necessarily innovative.
There was college
opportunity in every state
and federal prison
across the United States
for a generation, until 1994,
with the Clinton crime dome.
And so what we've done at
Bard is build an institution
which really sets the
tone and sets the standard
for the return of real
educational opportunity,
and real hope, and real meaning,
in our prison systems
across the United States.
And the students that
you've seen in these videos,
it's so important to remember,
are not analogous to,
are not in someway like,
but they are exactly the same people
who our last generation
of most distinguished
social scientists, and
leaders in governments,
and in education, described
as super predators.
Who we built a giant
multi-billion apparatus
to keep away from us.
And this cynicism that
was involved in that
was not limited to some
imaginary terrible people.
We were all culpable in it,
and the kind of cynicism
that led to those decisions,
I think were not limited
to law enforcement.
They also included the great leaders
of the most important secular,
liberal institutions in American life.
And those are our
colleges and universities.
There is not anyone in
this room who thinks that,
in my opinion, that any of
our college and universities
are doing what they need to do to prepare
this next generation of
Americans for the challenges
we face in the 21st century.
So at Bard, our idea
is how do we refashion,
how do we smash the way
we've done college admission
in the United States, and engage
as many kinds of Americans
as we possibly can in the
most ambitious, most rigorous,
most dignified kind of a
education we possibly could?
And so the kinds of students you saw here,
just to name a few, our friend Jewel,
who you see released from
prison in this video, decided,
was so inspired by continental
literature and philosophy,
decided he wanted to learn German
so he could read Hegel, and Heideggar
in the original, right?
And Sebastian who you see,
talking in such a beautiful way
about his inner life in this video,
right now is writing a senior thesis
on the impact of Japan's invasion of Korea
and that's how that has born out
in Korean culture over the years.
And at our last BA
graduation, two years ago,
at Eastern Correctional Facility,
a full half of those graduates,
incarcerated men of all
ages, a full half of them,
were majors in mathematics.
How far does that go to
puncture the liberal prejudice
that's, you find in every part of life,
of who's interested in what
and who's capable of what.
And we were very lucky a few years ago,
we've benefited from the friendship
of the Archdiocese of New York,
and we spent some time with the cardinal,
Cardinal Tim Dolan, and he said something
that I try repeat
virtually everywhere I go.
Which is that the church believes
that God continues
creation through education.
And as you know, in the Jewish tradition,
we believe that learning
itself is a form of prayer.
And when I think of the accomplishments
of your grandfather, Jack,
and of your accomplishments
already and to come, Mayor Brown,
I think at this moment in American life,
when we define success so exclusively
about how much money or
notoriety we accumulate.
And greed is the only value
that we share collectively
as a society, it seems.
I think it's so important to remember
that there are things we will
achieve, or fail at together,
politically, but to make
really truly lasting change,
we need to have the courage
to believe in ourselves,
and particularly young people,
and put individuals at
the center of that change.
And a return to the faith in
education and the power of it
in our opinion is the best way to do it,
and the only way for us not to continue,
and more importantly, not to
repeat the moral catastrophe
that mass incarceration
has become in our lifetime.